when I was being traditionally published
my first book deal was fifty thousand
dollars I did five more deals my final
book deal was for two thousand dollars
how much money can an author expect to
make on their first book let's say they
have a publisher involved well
publishing has changed so much since
when I got into it in 2005.
um back then I will tell you I'm very
I'm always very tacky and open about
money I got paid fifty thousand dollars
for my first book from harpercollins and
I was devastated because I knew all
these people who were making you know
getting hundreds of thousands of dollars
this was actually almost at the same
time that Hollywood was paying a lot of
money for spec scripts too
now I hear about advances that are five
to ten thousand dollars
publishing is an even more broken
business than Hollywood the way
publishing works is that they know
they're going to really make the bulk of
their money off of probably one or two
books all year and they're going to put
all their marketing and all their
promotion and all their efforts between
you know into those few books and they
consider everything else just a loss
leader they're just sort of throwing it
out you know 99 of books do not earn out
their advance so and the way that works
is so I was paid fifty thousand dollars
so that harpercollins has a situation
where they've got they're going to spend
fifty thousand dollars on you know the
editing and the cover and all of the
things and then once it comes starts to
come in then you know you split your
percentage with your publisher I've
never earned out most authors have never
earned out so obviously if you get a
lower Advance you're going to earn out
more quickly
but basically the way the way publishing
works is there are these books that are
you know the 50 Shades of Gray the Eat
Pray Love The Glenn and Doyle books
whatever those are and they most of the
population doesn't read so for a book to
hit basically it has to hit a segment of
the population that doesn't read where
people are going to be going to parties
and someone will say oh did you read Eat
Pray Love or did you read 50 Shades of
Gray and they're going to feel stupid
that they haven't read it so a book just
goes crazy when people who don't even
read books are reading it
um and so and so those are the books
there's just there's no there used to be
something called the mid list author the
midlist author would sell you know 5 000
copies of a book 8 000 copies of the
book now it's just the millions and
millions or the people that are selling
you know books under a thousand copies
what about if you become a New York
Times best-selling author how does life
change that is interesting because it
you can hit the New York Times
bestseller list selling 3 000 copies
it's all depends on what else is being
released that week and you know the
Bible has never hit the New York Times
bestseller list because it's about the
amount of sales in a particular week any
of the New York Times list as opposed to
the Wall Street journalists or the USA
Today list they admit that it is a sort
of editorial decision it's actually
William blatty who wrote The Exorcist
his
second book Legion
he sued the New York Times because he
said you know this was only briefly on
the list I know how many copies it sold
it went to court and New York Times said
in court this is actually an editorial
decision so that is something that uh
they are they they admitted in court
so the big misconception is that if you
hit the New York Times list you're set
for life not at all true I know
so many New York Times best-selling
authors who are completely broke and I
know people who have self-published
books that have sold 200 copies that are
living large so I was never more broke
than when I was a New York Times
best-selling author
was that perception an eye-opener for
you I know you said that you thought
once you sell these rights once you get
this book life will be wonderful I
think inspires more delusion delusions
than Hugh Grant movies people go into it
I was one of them you go in and you have
this book and everyone says to you like
don't get your hopes up you know this
phone doesn't happen for very many
people and you're like yeah yeah it's
gonna be different for me and I
experience it and I have now witnessed
probably hundreds of people I know who
have done the same thing and I can tell
when I'm talking to them and I and I try
to you know give them my gentle love of
like no no no this doesn't work don't
compare yourself to the exception you
know compare yourself to the rule and
and they just kind of give me this look
of like no it'll be different for me so
I have found I have never been someone
whose life has changed overnight as a
result of anything I know that does
happen to people but I also know people
who had
crazy hits out of the gate their first
book went crazy and they spend the rest
of their career living in like the glory
of their past I wouldn't want that
either I want my greatest success to be
in front of me not behind me
right I think it was an Elizabeth
wurtzel uh Prozac or yeah and David
Foster wall yeah they had had these hits
right out of the gate and I know other
people who are still alive who that
happened to as well right and there's
other things that come with it too
because I think then you're kind of
always like sneer dad in that world
because you're the one that was the was
the darling out of the gate and I think
that's a hard thing to live up to as
well I think it is I think it is I mean
yeah right right but anyway it's
different I know I get it it's going to
be different for me I understand right
every it's always different what if you
self-publish what is money like then
well I will say when I was being
traditionally published my first book
deal was fifty thousand dollars I did
five more deals my final book deal was
for two thousand dollars two thousand
dollars so it worked out to about I
guess like a quarter of a penny a day
for like my amount of work
no money comes from Book Sales like I
will say this until I'm like blue in the
face so self-publishing yes you can make
more money from Book Sales because your
percentage is going to be higher but
never look at it as the book sales I'm
obsessed with like what is the back end
so I write books now that bring people
they bring attention to my company they
add to my credibility as a publisher as
an author as all of these things so yeah
I'll make like a couple thousand dollars
on Book Sales but I can bring in
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
clients so I think the whole perception
has to change when we're talking about
money just not even I wanted to start a
podcast called like screw Book Sales
like it's not about the book sales it's
about there's no better credibility
Builder there's no better business card
there is no better way to say I am an
expert than to publish a book book so
why would you do that be the world be
one of the world's experts and have
everyone want to hire you and be worried
about the counting the Pennies on the
book sales it just doesn't make sense
when you talked about Bill blattey or
William blatty you know with the
Exorcist and then he had several other
books I believe and you said there was
this this lawsuit back then was it more
what people expect and it's drastically
changed now well publishing just Jeff
Bezos changed publishing when
self-publishing went from like your
creepy uncle's book that was like the
the garage was filled with this book he
was always passing out you know family
reunions that was self-publishing when
Amazon changed and they created um KDP
where anybody could actually go in and
publish a book it changed everything I
mean self-publishing isn't new Stephen
King his self-published Jane Austen
self-published it's not new but the way
it can be done now the level at which it
can be done it's indistinguishable from
a traditionally published New York Times
best-selling book so the thing the
problem with that is that people go
great I mean we could in the next 10
minutes publish a book on Amazon that
doesn't mean it's gonna be good
um but so the distinction Now isn't
between what's traditionally published
and what's self-published but what's
published at the highest level and what
isn't published at the highest level
what are the different ways that an
author is paid
um so you mean with traditional or just
in general or self yeah
um so if you're traditionally published
you're paid your Advance which is
usually broken up into threes which is
you know here's here's the third then
the second third is when you turn it in
and then the third third is when you
release it if you're self-published or
you're paying a company to publish
you're gonna put the money out and then
it's up to you how you want to make the
money back
um what we do for our clients will put a
QR code at the beginning of the book If
you put it at the beginning of the book
because of Amazon's look inside feature
people who don't even buy the book could
theoretically get whatever it is so
people put on QR codes on the beginning
of their book they can you can put on
the QR on the barcode on the back you
can put it throughout and people do all
sorts of things there are um there is a
a writer named he's a marketer writer
named Pat Flynn who put a he has a book
called will it Fly great book and it's
all about like is your business idea
viable he created a free course that the
there's links throughout the book to the
free course from that free course the
people who signed up he sold them a paid
course and um the person who helped him
do that I had on my podcast and he said
through that he made a hundred and
eleven thousand dollars not from his
full email list just from the list of
the people who read the book and signed
up for the free course I don't know many
authors that are making a hundred and
eleven thousand dollars on their launch
day but that's the kind of thing that's
possible what do you mean when you say
you're not going to make money from Book
Sales so the book should be about your
secret power
I mean that people read a how-to book
because they want to solve a problem
they want to know how to do something
and so a book should show somebody who
wants to know how to do something how
they can do it but at the same time show
how much more complicated the thing is
to do than they might have thought so
somebody who could afford to would then
want to pay somebody to do it for them
and who better to pay than the person
who wrote the book on the topic on top
of the advance what about royalties
well you're talking to someone who never
earned royalties
um because they you don't royalties
don't kick in until after they have paid
out the advance so so that's why authors
who just get like you know no advance or
very minimal advances can earn back the
I don't know the exact percentages
because it's never been relevant for me
but trust me it's not in the author's
favor
so the more you get up front almost like
a film distribution deal the better you
are are you getting an accounting every
month
yes I mean my accountings are terribly
depressing
um yeah I mean you get an account uh I
still think I get accountings on books
of mine where they're like no book sales
for this month or whatever it is but um
but yeah like I said I just think
looking at the book sales is is a losing
game
do you own the rights to all of your
books
I only own the rights to party girl and
then uh how to get Successful by effing
up your life and make your mess your
Memoir I sold uh the rights to five of
my books to Harper and then one to Simon
and Schuster with party girl I was able
to get the rights back which was an
incredible thing because I knew the
movie was gonna get made and I always
hated the cover and I just basically
decided Well Harper Collins doesn't care
about this book I really care about this
book when the book came out Judith Regan
had been fired in the worst Scandal to
ever hit publishing so all these High
Hopes they had for the book there wasn't
you know they talk in publishing about
if your editor leaves to go to another
house you've been orphaned and I always
said it's like the I was orphan and the
orphanage was built to the ground there
was there was no office anymore so back
then in 2007 bookstores mattered a lot
lot and the way Publishers got books
into bookstores is they would send sales
representatives there were no sales
representatives so the book was sort of
DOA even though there was all this buzz
and all the movie rights and all of
these things in order to get the rights
back my contract um stipulated that I
got them back within 10 years but we
still had to get it official and so it
was very complicated my lawyer sent um a
lot you know letters to Harper Collins
but because the division was gone there
was no one to approve it I had to get my
agent involved and then finally at a
certain point I said I don't care I
don't think Harper's gonna care if I
re-release it so I had my cover designer
do this amazing cover I decided I wanted
to release it in September because it
was addiction recovery month and I was
like you know what they can come after
me hey it'll be good publicity if they
actually care and I already had plans to
release the book and the the day before
I get a letter it's like congratulations
you've got your rights back and I'm like
thanks didn't even need it no Scandal
darn okay yeah
is 10 years a common length of time I
actually don't know I don't know
um I think when a publisher really
values a book that they're gonna fight
to keep it but it was almost like they
cared so little that's why it was hard
to get them back because there was just
no one who was even involved anymore